Олексій Гончаренко європейська
Солідарність шановні друзі Сьогодні
Україна потерпає від тероризму найбільше
з усіх країн світу Це очевидно і ми
маємо добиватися визнання російського
режиму терористичним це вже зроблено в
парламентській асамблеї Ради Європи яка
згідно поправки поданої нашої
Української делегацією підтримала це
після того ми бачимо як це вже прийнято
Литва Латвії Естонія Польща Чехія Я
впевнений що на наступному тижні
долучиться європейські парламент і це
буде дуже серйозно Ми маємо всі над цим
працювати для того щоб всі назвати речі
своїми іменами що російський режим
терористичний ми бачимо а останнє це
Чехія яка вже проголосувала ми бачимо що
насправді цей терорист вже вийшов за
межі України і ми бачимо як вчора
загинули люди в Польщі від того
тероризму який робить Росія і це каже
сьогодні на весь світ сама Польща що
Дивіться що відбувається що та війна
розпочала Росія Яка які вони має
наслідки і тому друзі це треба безумовно
розглядати але я хотів би ще сказати що
ми всією країною маємо
об'єднатися навколо боротьби саме з цим
з державою терористом російської
федерацію вона жаль ми бачимо як знову
повертаються справи проти нашої
колижанки Софії федини і Марусі звіробій
яка воює сьогодні за Україну при тому що
піднімали вони тему золотого і відступу
з нього за Яке зараз Україна віддає своє
життя І дуже багато життів ми бачимо що
продовжується справа проти Генерала
Марченко які воюють за Україну проти
сашка-погребисько з його звинувачують в
нападі на кого наголошена який зрадник
збіг і сидить десь в Москві а ми далі
дивимось на це опсж яке Сидить тут і ні
прибираємо їх з українського парламенту
от таких речей не має бути маємо всі
об'єднатися навколо одного боротьби з
тероризмом з державою терористом Росією
і тільки так друзі Ми переможемо